hey everyone I'm Jason Horton the
world's only white male comedian and my
channel youtube.com / jaysmith morning
when did you start here in 2009 and i
just i think i calculated i've been in
like three hundred million viewed videos
so excited about that i just want you to
be x comic and i'm gonna film called
smiley out of 10 11 12 my first movie
and i may or not may not be wearing
clothes in it Wow yes we'll stick to the
PG 10 so when you started your channel
did you start like hugging everybody was
a tiny chihuahua I come from an improv
and sketch comedy background so I kind
of found you to second where other
people kind of switch that so I started
just working with a bunch of different
sketch comedians and just I just are
doing this YouTube thing and I realized
let me put this back at myself I used
YouTube alike look up like guitar
tutorial and then I kind of just kind of
figured out how this all works and then
I found a nice home wit community and
was able to leave my my desktop Wow yeah
as if he was right after a Jew thing no
one except don't don't wish you have you
know a backpack in like when I was to do
2007 2008 2009 I think people didn't
realize there was money there I think
money is unfortunately what kind of
defines success and I was like you know
great you know if I take a raise your
hand if you have the Internet everyone
raise your hand if I say to who has
cable not many hands go up I also do a
lot of the consultation and I
kind of help adults reality TV and
that's always the the kind of a like
monitor thing I use just raising your
hand yes or now people take it super
seriously so in 2009 you started if you
look at ease your pain event together
now what about this offer I think it was
easier to get subscribers getting the
views I collaborate so much and uh you
know I've pretty large social media
always built that up and I always make
sure i was always responsive to fans and
commentators where other people just
didn't have to survive I found that
tonight was and I can't do it a hundred
percent I've always been known for being
very approachable and he's kind of very
giving adjust your super thankful I
think it's got a paid off are you